l'instant vérité chris marquès déjà
répond à la polémique sur le départ de
pamela anderson
on avait révélé dans tpm paix lundi soir
qu'à aucun moment dans les contrats et
participants il existait une mention
autorisant le joker dont a bénéficié
pamela pamela m'envoyer un long sms que
je vais vous lire dans un instant et
marquez en anglais vous nous dire en
anglais chris marquez a réagi à cette
polémique
chez jean marc morandini sur ses news
regardez ce qu'il a dit chris marquez
dit on va vous dire dans un instant si
pamela va danser ou pas on a toutes les
infos jean michel a encore été très bon
allez l'émission est vraiment basée sur
ce que vous voyez c'est à dire si la
performance est bonne les juges vous
note en tant que tel et ensuite vous
avez le vote du public
on ne peut pas en fait faire signer les
artistes si on leur dit vous pouvez
négocier le nombre de semaines que vous
allez faire sur les mystères et le fait
qu'elle essayait pour quatre contrats
c'est faux vous notre site clairement il
faut ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas et
donc c'est un gala samedi prochain par
elle sera là en tout cas ça c'est sûr
maintenant je sais je vais pouvoir
danser je ne sais mais c'est le
lancement elle est éliminée elle sera
éliminée donc elle sera restée quatre
émissions comme thomas resté cinq ans et
demi
alors est-ce qu'elle va danser ou pas
pamela samedi soir on va vous le dire
tout de suite
déjà là de ce que dit chris marquez et
j'adore crise où on sait qu' il ya des
contrats qui sont sur trois quatre
émissions puissions y apparaît arielle
dombasle qui l'a dit elle-même cheylon
qui espère-t-on j'adore chris marquez
henry foot et pamela m'envoyer un
message à imbaba warsaw kind tout
supporter mais on est tellement gentil
de me supporter et wanted to express
personally man appréciation ça veut dire
elle m'a dit je vais te dire je vais te
dire mon assurance the bull ring à
dallas la règle de dams est très
chanceuse pour moi il ce qui permis
puisque bon je vais le prendre en france
ce que je peux la voir en france elle
m'a dit en fait voilà qu'elle est en
train de s'entraîner cette semaine
voilà je m'entraîne très dur j'ai fait
des examens le clean et et l'ostéo sont
avec moi je vais faire une deuxième irm
très vite pour savoir si je vais pouvoir
danser ou pas elle prends des anti
inflammatoires
elle veut danser absolument samedi soir
mais va-t-elle le faire lé voilà elles
sont reines
elle essayait de s'entraîner et à
faisait estime j'ai la meilleure équipe
autour de moi je suis blessé voilà elle
retournera à paris vendredi pour savoir
si elle va danser ou pas mais on a la
réponse déjà jean michel maire est
est-ce que ça intéresse samir déjà le
fait qu'elle reste pas dans l'émission
ouais franchement je m'emballe est merci
merci ça vire dans béziers c'est un mec
de mérule alors évidemment d'enquêté et
de il ya une heure encore moi j'ai
appris que l dans serait effectivement
samedi qu'elle ne déclaraient pas
forfait au début d'émission auquel
participeraient comme les autres autour
note danse et qu'elle jugerait après
deux ans en fonction de dépréciations et
cetera de elle reste ou pas mais va
danser peut-être qu'elle danse a su sur
un mât l'ordre mal et qu'elle serait
limitée parce qu'elle danse mal mais
elle va danser concède le nul est donc
pamela va danser voilà je vous le dis
elle va danser qui quittent qu'est la
même info le mans qui bosse moi je vous
le dis j'ai les infos et pamela voilà me
l'a dit elle même elle dansera samedi
soir elle va faire ce qu'elle peut pas
mais là mais elle va tout faire pour
danser samedi soir donnant c'est christ
à elle va essayer de rester dans la
voiture
est-ce que vous pensez que des fins
essayer de la faire entrer et rester
dans la voiture pour s'ériger sur pas du
tout ça mais ils peuvent plus ils
pouvaient pas maintenant la faire ou
quoi mais là s'inquiète pas honte à
protéger ma chérie tu sortiras plus tôt
je peux te dire et c'est impossible cnet
us or voilà le seul regret il y aura pas
moscato mais bien sûr et pamela dansera
voilà je voulais vous le diront